ray tracing sounds a bit like the name
of some bloke who plays darts with your
dad on a sunday afternoon
but in case you're not aware it is in
fact one of the most powerful techniques
when it comes to adding a dose of
realism to your video games
it's long been something that only pc
players could flaunt showing off
impressive rays of soft light and
reflections
while their graphics cards start to get
warmer and warmer
and their system fans screech for a
crumb of cool air
but in recent years the technology has
become more accessible and available to
players
now arriving alongside the new
generation of consoles with some games
tapping into the power of the xbox
series x
and s as well as the playstation 5 to
produce the jaw-dropping lights and
shadows that were previously
reserved for only the thickest of pc
rigs but how does ray tracing
actually work and be you a pc xbox or
playstation gamer
should you really care basically ray
tracing casts out and calculates linear
rays of light between
in-game light sources and the player's
eye this is rendered in real time as the
rays bounce off whatever surfaces they
hit
going from object to object and reacting
accordingly
until the image is displayed on screen
ray tracing also calculates reactions
from different surfaces like glass or
water
and how the light will reflect refract
and be absorbed differently
these calculations lead to a more
accurate representation of how light
works in the real world
areas obstructed by objects or blocks
from light rays are properly
darkened as a result which goes some way
into creating more accurate shadows
and the scene's illumination looks more
realistic scenes are able to represent
changes to lighting conditions since
rays are being cast and calculated in
real time
making for realistic and dynamic
environments
traditionally games have made more use
of baked in lighting
and some extremely clever tricks of the
trade to produce some convincing and
realistic results
but these are often predetermined
animations and renders that are much
more static
this means that if you start messing
with the object within an environment
and the light stays the same the
illumination that the game is providing
starts to look
out of place without ray tracing if you
interrupt a light source by moving an
object or standing in front of the
lights
nothing really changes with ray tracing
however you can see your interactions
and the changes in your environment in
real time
not every ray is calculated however
because well
that would be a gargantuan task in the
real world
approximately half a billion photons hit
your eye every second
to produce the image you're seeing now
with ray tracing only the most important
rays are being processed
and machine learning algorithms fill in
the gaps between them through a process
called denoising then programs use the
player's viewpoint to work out what rays
are actually being seen at any one point
and any potentially well lit ray tracing
goodness that could
be happening outside of that point of
view are ignored
procedures like these go ways to
reducing the computing power needed when
using this tech
now this is obviously very impressive
stuff utilizing some extremely clever
technology and going a long way
in increasing graphic fidelity in our
video games but it doesn't come for free
ray tracing can be a big drain on your
system's gpu
especially at higher resolutions so it
often comes to a toss-up of what you
want out of your gaming experience
if you want these fancy shadows and
real-time lighting effects your frame
rate is going to suffer
how much is dependent on the game of
course but it's worth noting
that many cases opting in or out of this
feature will provide a different gaming
experience
watchdog's legions can be run on the
xbox series x with 4k
and ray tracing enabled locked at 30
frames a second
but if you want to take advantage of a
higher frame rate for a smoother
experience
you'll have to disable ray tracing
capcom says that ray tracing will be
available with two of the devil may cry
5's gameplay modes on release
specifically a 4k and 30fps mode and
1080p at 60fps
if you want to play the game 120 frames
however you'll have to do so
with no ray tracing for cinematic games
that focus more on the world environment
and exploration
games like control for example the
experience may be improved with ray
tracing enabled
while we don't know how much the frame
rate will be affected for multiplayer
shooters like call of duty black ops
cold war however
it's often recommended to remain
competitive in multiplayer the higher
the frame rate the better
how these games and their ray tracing
offerings hold up on our new home
hardware however
only time will tell nevertheless all
these compromises have also been the
case for the pc player base 2
but now for the first time the
technology has made its way to consoles
thanks to the power crammed into the
xbox series x
series s and the playstation 5. now it's
more accessible than ever
and personally i'm hoping that with that
accessibility comes more developers
willing to experiment with real purdy
lighting
and rad shadows but what option are you
going to run with will ray tracing be
enabled at every opportunity
or are you more focused on a triple
digit frame rate let us know in the
comment section below and if you want to
learn more about the hardware and tech
inside your console
you can watch this video where john link
breaks down whatever the heck
teraflop is thank you for watching and
we will see you
next time
[Music]
you